Dos funciones "f" y "g" están descritas a continuación.
¿Cuál de las afirmaciones presentadas es correcta?
Me dan "f" que está descrita
como esta ecuación lineal, muy tradicional,
"f" entonces representa una línea recta
y tengo a "g" que esta graficada da aquí.
Bien, mis opciones son,
tanto "f" como "g" son crecientes
y "g" crece más rápido que "g".
Pues no tenemos que "g" para empezar,
no es una función creciente,
"g" no es una función creciente,
porque mientras "x" se hace más grande
el valor que toma "g" se hace cada vez más pequeño.
De hecho,
este tampoco es una función creciente,
es una línea con pendiente negativa.
Su pendiente es de menos siete tercios,
por lo tanto "f" también es decreciente y puedo descartar esta opción.
Tanto "f" como "g" son crecientes,
de nuevo, puedo descartar esta inmediatamente.
Tanto "f" como "g" son decrecientes,
y "f" decrece más rápido que "g",
pues veamos,
¿Cuál es la pendiente g?
100 "g", si me paro en este punto,
y me muevo en una unidad
hacia la derecha
entonces tengo que bajar
dos unidades para regresar a la gráfica,
de modo que la pendiente "g"
¿cuánto es?
La pendiente es el cambio en "y"
dividido entre el cambio en "x".
Mi cambio en "x" fue de 1,
moví una unidad a la derecha
y mi cambio en "y" fue de -2,
baje dos unidades.
De modo que la pendiente "g" es -2,
pero la pendiente de "f" es de -7 tercios
y -7 tercios es lo mismo que,
que el número mixto,
-2 con un tercio,
y -2 con un tercio es menor que -2.
Así que "f" está decreciendo más rápido que "g".
Tanto "f" como "g" son decrecientes
y "g" decrece más rápido que "f",
pues acabo de decir que "f"
decrece más rápido que "g",
por lo tanto,
esta opción tampoco es correcta
y finalmente "g" es creciente pero "f" es decreciente
"g" es decreciente también,
así que también puedo descartar esta opción.